tells then about that breaking news this
lunchtime over a fifth vaccine johnson
and johnson making that announcement at
one o'clock this afternoon
at the vaccines understood to be one of
the cheapest at around seven
pounds per dose just one dose is
required
although trials of two doses are ongoing
well the vaccine can be kept
refrigerated between
two and eight degrees celsius for up to
three months and the uk
has secured 30 million doses of the jab
while the united states has made a deal
for a hundred million and the eu
has secured 200 million let's bring in
our science correspondent
thomas moore who joins us now it's like
waiting for a bus
isn't it thomas to wait for these
vaccines then two come along in one day
yes this is the second wave of vaccines
which is coming through
and the thing that really dis makes this
uh
separates this from the rest is that
this is a single dose vaccine the first
single dose vaccine and it does get
pretty good results uh not as good
perhaps as the the results we've heard
from
novavax in the last 24 hours but
nevertheless
a hugely significant leap forward so
what they've shown is that in the united
states where they did a huge trial
uh 72 percent of people were protected
from
moderate to severe covid 19.
they also tested it interestingly in
south america
and in south africa and they got good
protection there so
in in latin america it was 66 percent
south africa 57
that's where of course we've got new
variants the virus emerging
and the fact that it does get still
pretty good levels of protection there
better than the flu vaccine would for
example against the flu virus
does show that this is a decent vaccine
now why is one dose significant
because it can be rolled out so much
more quickly that you could
extend this far into low and middle
income
countries very rapidly they have hardly
had any
doses of the vaccine so far and it's at
low cost
seven pounds a dose to protect somebody
and that's roughly the same as two doses
of the oxford vaccine so
very significant that this has achieved
its
initial goal of one dose being effective
but as you say
two doses are being tested in further
clinical trials